hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to among the sleep
we're about to take this evil evil evil
evil teddy bear unless you send the
comments otherwise I don't quite know
yet because I've been recording straight
from the last one we're gonna take him
and we're gonna go on a little bit of an
adventure down into this tube that's
gonna take us to another nightmare land
I hope this one is scarier than the last
one in a way that last one was
exceptionally creepy I mean nothing
actually happened I think something may
have been after me I don't know when I
got up and ran but I'm not exactly sure
but I'm eagerly awaiting what lies in
the darkness all good this is exactly
what I was hoping for darkness darkness
darkness and more darkness my favorite
darkness by bulk skully click perfect
Teddy come save me from the darkness you
do shine light but maybe that's an evil
evil light you thought we should keep
quiet before look with that got us there
trees and the hallways things are
falling apart I'm a mama is all gone
what more good can you bring me then
again maybe this guy is totally good and
I'm just misjudging and I'm a terrible
judge of character but I played enough
horror games to kind of know where this
may be leading me
o pretty-pretty I don't remember having
a house big enough to have a chandelier
is that count Dracula's sarcophagus
they're sarcophagi are from Egypt that
is not what I was talking about coffin
maybe sir Kyle the guy those floaty
things they look like memory
oh those maybe the next one is behind
those roots maybe there's something I
can see over here there's some aha I
knew there was something let's see what
we have I got a puppy
I got a puddle piece I got a puzzle
piece yes I did I got a puzzle piece yes
I your squid I can't I gotta put a piece
in my pants I got a puzzle piece oh I
need to pull that off I see so I have a
puzzle piece here oh how interesting is
that did I see something standing there
before that allgäu removed not entirely
sure what you want from me but here we
go
Danny who who's over here hello animated
painting what is this Harry Potter that
looks disturbing
oh it's mario64 up in this [ __ ] I'm
gonna go through the paintings and see
what I trouble I can get into am I gonna
get some magic stars no I'm gonna get
some more nightmares good thing we're
going out into the woods I was worried
that it was gonna be cozy and safe in
there it was a little too warm and
inviting if you know what I mean could
have used some sprucing up let's not
fall to our death immediately I haven't
died yet I don't even know if I can but
let's just try to avoid it for now hello
anything in here I need was that me
walking through the grass that better
stay me or else goddess
okay thank you am I still picking my
belly button over there yes I am good
for me at least I don't have to worry
about bellybutton lint but maybe I have
to worry about monsters Cronk thank you
very much I appreciate being into Bayou
where crocodiles could just snap me up
alligators I don't know what's more huh
by you I don't even know what a bayou is
is this what the hell is that it's at a
drawer oh my god it was a drawer in a
tree why uh Teddy I need your help here
climbing climbing climbing thank you
now where am I going okay I don't know
if I'm missing anything because it seems
like there's a lot of paths to go but
let's just try this one for now because
kind of had me looping around before I'm
not I'm not gonna be surprised if it has
me going back a few times I am looking
for a puzzle piece oh well is that is
that where they breathe is filmed so are
the Frog bubbly douches going up there
uh thank you this kid has to deal with
those cow frog face things I am NOT
gonna be very happy about that okay I
think I could might be able to climb up
there I think is that's what it wants me
to do and then when I climb up here I
can get through the window and I have no
idea what's going on I may seem like I
know what's going on but I have no idea
it's some weird combination of trees and
interior decoration I'm gonna assume
that the Frog died and that was an
alternate universe with a frog did not
defeat the thing at the bottom of the
lake
Oh turn the darkness good oh there's a
nice rumble oh isn't that it's just a
delightful rumble thank you I'm sure
that it signals my impending doom
hey if it's okay I'll pass I'll pass
this one time I'll pass
hello n in block why do I need you what
is that oh god that's a head thank you
for the nice accompanying scream but I
didn't need that I stare ahead there are
there more heads in here why are their
heads oh that's not a head it's like a
clown car thingy oh god it's a skull is
that a skull no it's a potato I don't
know what that is I want to say that's a
potato over a skull so uh Oh God
thank you I still didn't find a puzzle
piece I don't know if I missed it I
think I need to find two more at least
before I'm able to get to the memory oh
how convenient
oh you look much better than that one
that was made of shadows and death so
thank you for not being a nightmare got
it oh that was that was that was that
well it's getting hot in here yeah that
I'm getting slightly stressed can I get
back up this way I don't know I can get
back up that way oh wait this is
different okay so I opened that or maybe
I don't or maybe I do
I don't really know it seems kind of
linear this game I would like a bit more
freeform exploration but hey it's still
pretty good can't go wrong whoa where
did I go I did not see that alright I'm
still alive for us
what huh Hey
let the witch in the swamp I just spit
incredible cloud in front of my eyes
sorry any notion what happened Oh Oh go
don't eat me
I'm a baby wait a baby what are you a
baby I couldn't see where I was going it
fell right in why did you eat a baby do
I still have it good I still have it
geez you just ate up a baby are you
happy with yourself I was hoping to get
through this whole game without dying
you son of a [ __ ] you ass you poopy ass
okay so that's why I need to go sorry
it's a little bit dark I can't exactly
see where I'm going my teddy does not
choose to stay out in the open all the
time okay let us not fall in the river
and die a horrible mangled death well
how did I fall I was walking right here
how did I fall in there that is hardly
fair that is hardly my fault actually
don't you kill me you bastard I do not
want to die not in a horrible mangled
way Thank You teddy I should be cut from
hair [ __ ] just need to go over there and
put the puzzle piece in the other slag
okay sorry they breathe bad people oh I
just fell over nevermind are you
munching up my ankles
do you know every image we done
yeah there's never anything that's
actually happening in this game it's all
just what I think is going on it's
messing with me and I don't appreciate
it I'm gonna try to make this episode
all of this memories feels yeah let's
not dwell here for too long that wasn't
my plan so you know maybe you could shut
up and only give me good advice what do
we have over here Oh sad mama by the
well is that some of the lady that I
okay she just slammed a bucket in her
face either though was she going to
drown herself
why does a little kids need to know
about that is this about that story that
that teddy bear read with a five on the
hill wanted to get a drink they ended up
all dying no thank you
okay I'll go this way uh let's see what
you got what do you got ha bring it on
I'm very tough Connie just getting hot
in this room I'm sweating up a storm can
I climb on that new gonna crawl under
that new what do I do turtle in a box is
this a clue it's a man of shadows this a
turtle over an electrical plug so I'm
supposed to take a fork and plug it into
a wall socket all righty then let's go
under here open up this venture Unni
crawl in because little kids are
supposed to go in enclosed spaces
they're supposed to crawl ugh
okay that's cool - Thank You Man thank
you for that thank you for the boots I
like it a lot get her out of here we got
over here get up in the Denny bear this
is gonna be a fun time for me it's gonna
be a fun adventure do I need to go up
over the air no I just need to scoot
that open so I can open the thing with
the thing
hey look it's daddy's happy juice I
wanna just slug that down cuz I'm a
child without any supervision excuse me
Arden what the hell is that what is with
these shadow creatures in this child's
mind okay don't like the rumble Rumble
is a bad thing thank you huh
why what are you doing stop making those
sounds on them
No No
I knew it was gonna be bad I didn't know
who's gonna be fat
what was that is it still there oh it's
not good good good then where I was last
time in the last puzzle piece god what
was that thing uh-huh
I really didn't expect anything to
actually be there all good total
darkness
my favorite anybody there is anybody out
there
I'm the teddy bear I think that we
should go into the most dangerous blaze
and hunt for the most dangerous things
instead of staying in your room where it
was all safe because I'm an [ __ ] or
something like that I don't need your
sass I just want to be done wanna get
this puzzle piece no no our I say no to
pretty much anything that you are trying
to sell me that sounds jingling nice I
got a feeling it ain't all right listen
I'll play your game oh god one of these
things with the turn angles and I need
to move my mouse a million billion times
I'm a strong little boy as easy
okay harder thing I heard a thing you
can't tell me I didn't hear a thing good
headphones I know and things are
happening okay okay cool I like it I
like it a lot I like it I mean I don't
like it cool I'm just gonna go on now
let it go I'm gonna go away I'm gonna go
away forever
you don't mind that was that what am I
supposed to do with that it's a big
piece of triangle no look at oh oh wait
a minute wait a minute that's a triangle
damn it
no it couldn't be that easy they
wouldn't have just given it to me like
that okay so you're there you're over
there that's where I saw the oh it's
boarded up now good good good wouldn't
want to be too easy on me put Teddy away
so I can run around a bit where am I
supposed to go what am I supposed to do
oh there was something else in the
bucket I'm an idiot humming you idiot
okay so let's carry on
I get the triangle piece so I can unlock
this lock and carry on with my life come
on move how do I here we go yeah but but
it's an easy lock
easy enough for a child to handle it a
two-year-old to be specific the
whispering hi lady
oh goodness gravy
it's good Caillat maybe not lady lady
lady you're not gonna kill me huh yeah
that's cool it's also cool how about you
never harm you again I think you're a
lady anyway lady they drink from the
well the poison well they threw yourself
into the river which way do I go
Amy money there's a light over here
thanks daddy that lady comes I'm gonna
throw you in the way and hope she gets
you and not me okay Hey look another
painting I wonder what it says hide
under the table for the shadow whatever
doozy maybe that's what it said maybe
not I don't know I'm just a kid I
probably made him though is that swamp
over there god I'm literally sweating up
a storm over here what am I supposed to
do I already got the puzzle piece can I
go home
how about I go home how about I go to
home now we want home me one home please
for me okay I just know something else
is gonna happen I know it I know these
things I'm very smart and intuitive you
love it alrighty then carrying on as if
I didn't scream like a little girl is
this the way out what is a supposed to
do
what am I doing with this Oh God what
what do I do with this let my supposed
to do this what do I do with this I have
it but why hmm come on
Oh
can I go into there no maybe Hey look
kid moving lumber oh I'm very strong
baby this obviously is me because I'm
incredibly strong got it do not know why
I need this can't I go home can't go
home yet I'll look more happy juice God
good another Oh God I'll set that down
for now I don't think I can even carry
it up with me Gilardi hello
alright I think this this part is
actually gone on for a bit too long so
I'm gonna have to stop it here hope you
guys don't mind I'm gonna pick it up
right away as soon as I can so either
way if you're enjoying the series let me
know in the comments leave a like down
below if you are thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
just got your turn assembly and during
the entire setting you think that guy
ran under your tires there's not
everyone